roland desbordes bonjour merci à vous
d'être avec nous en direct ce matin sur
rtl france alors aujourd'hui inscrire
tchernobyl au patrimoine mondial de
l'unesco
est-ce que cela a un sens pour vous non
hélas le site de tchernobyl et ainsi
d'une catastrophe nucléaire
je pense qu'il faut garder la mémoire
mais ça c'est évident mais pas pour pour
y faire venir des touristes parce que
classe et un site en patrimoine mondial
ça veut dire que on va faire venir faire
venir des gens or c'est un lieu où qui
est absolument pas fréquentable je dirai
et je suis choqué par le nombre de
touristes qui continue et qui augmentent
effectivement chaque année pour venir
il ya un côté morbide là dedans qui moi
me choque déjà beaucoup et puis il ya
c'est une zone à risque ce n'est pas un
une zone banal il y a des quantités de
déchets radioactifs
on a sécurisé le site avec ce sarcophage
hui c'est à dire en talk on voit bien là
mais qui ne protège de rien en fait
c'est tout c'est de la tôle
or on a tous les experts ne sont pas
absolument pas d'accord sur quel est
l'état à la d2 la matière nucléaire à
l'intérieur du des bâtiments qui ont des
accidents
j'ai justement on va y revenir dans un
instant à sur les conséquences de cette
catastrophe nucléaire mais mais avant je
souhaitais entendre alexandre catch and
co c'est le ministre ukrainien de la
culture estimant écouter d'offres sont
les touristes continuent d'affluer mais
tout ce qui se trouve là bas est en
train de tomber en ruine
nous pensons donc cartel patrimoine cas
tel héritage n'appartient pas seulement
aux ukrainiens mais à toute l'humanité
alors un héritage pour toute l'humanité
comment est ce que vous comprenez et
vous recevez cette phrase du ministre
ukrainien je veux bien qu'on parle
d'héritage mais quand on parle de
patrimoine pour moi je pense à des
vieilles pierres je pense à des as de la
culture je pense à autre chose qu'à une
catastrophe nucléaire c'est une question
de mots en fête pour moi qui est
important
je suis choqué que les ukrainiens
développe le tourisme dans cette région
là mais ils ont des tas d'autres
endroits pour faire venir les gens on
est dans une zone à risque
est ce que c'est pour leur faire essayer
de la faire comprendre ou admettre que
tchernobyl c'est fini non ce n'est pas
fini tchernobyl la catastrophe n'est pas
terminé il y a des quantités de déchets
radioactifs à traiter ils y allaient
combustible usé des réacteurs qui sont
même pas en sécurité
moi je suis désolé ce n'est pas
l'endroit où on peut attirer du monde
alors je suis profondément choquée que
on continue dans cette direction là
d'attirer du monde à tchernobyl parce
que ça d'ailleurs
qu'est ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs qu'est ce qu'on sait
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs de la
biodiversité sur place vous nous disiez
que c'était encore extrêmement dangereux
aujourd'hui de s'y rendre
oui bien sûr quand on va à tchernobyl en
fait on croit on à organiser des
circuits et heureusement on ne fait pas
circuler les gens dans les zones
contaminées les zones à danger
on les fait circuler sur la route on est
bien de faire des photos au pied du
sarcophage dans la vieille ville de
pripiat c'est des zones à risques mais
limitée par contre dès qu'on sort de ces
zones là évidemment ça on y est allés
nous la criirad et on a bien vu que dès
que vous sortez de ces zones balisées
l'arrêt de l'activité elle est énorme et
actuellement brillant il ya un film qui
est un documentaire qui vient de sortir
en france apple stores ping qui a donné
des idées à plein plein de jeunes
d'aller faire les fous c'est bien de la
folie d'aller dans ces zones en cachette
évidemment
pour faire avec des conteurs et qui sont
excités on peut pas s'imaginer qu'on
serrait avec les conteurs commence à
frétiller et les conséquences sur
l'homme est ce que on a eu une idée du
nombre on a ce rapport de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé établi en 2005 1
lui qui nous parle de 4000 personnes au
total qui pourrait être à terme qui
pourrait décéder à terme des suites de
leurs expositions aux substances
radioactives
on est dans la réalité c'est plus vous
avez d'autres chiffres non on est très
très loin de la réalité ce rapport de
l'om est-ce qu'il est scandaleux
il est fait sur les documents à partir
de documents et des informations
totalement erronées
les bills le bilan humain de tchernobyl
il n'est pas terminée et à ce que c'est
une catastrophe en cours pour les eaux
les gens qui vivent en zones contaminées
alors ça concerne surtout la biélorussie
et - l'ukraine mais le bilan de
tchernobyl on le fera que beaucoup
beaucoup plus tard mais ce chiffre de
4000 morts il sort d'un chapeau il n'a
jamais été établie à partir de bases
scientifiques
c'était le chiffre qu'il fallait sortir
pour que tchernobyl reste encore une
catastrophe industrielle acceptable du
point de vue des autorités
mais il n'a aucune réalité scientifique
rien que les liquidateurs qui sont
intervenus le 1 million de jeunes
liquidateur qui se sont qui sont partis
dans toute l'ex urss on en a perdu la
trace on ne sait pas mais on sait qu'à
des problèmes de santé
on ne voit les chiffres et aujourd'hui
honnêtement donc ces chiffres est
scandaleux quant à la biodiversité dans
la zone interdite
c'est normal vous l'homme a abandonné
cet espace en gros ça veut dire que la
nature a repris des droits mais la
nature n'est pas du tout la belle nature
que l'on connaît en apparence il y a des
feuilles aux arbres donc tout va bien il
ya quelques animaux mais on n'est pas du
tout devant un milieu de biodiversité
comme on peut trouver alors relents des
morts peut-être enfin en un mot pour
conclure à la question du nucléaire
elle est au coeur des débats notamment
avec la convention citoyenne sur le
climat en ce moment le sel de l'état
alors lui s'est déclaré pour le
nucléaire et en même temps pour les
énergies
renouvelables en quelques mots pour
conclure comment est ce que vous
comprenez cette position eh bien elle
est intenable
on ne peut pas faire les deux continuer
le nucléaire pour la france ça veut dire
investir des sommes colossales mais bien
énorme c 17 en centaines de milliards
d'euros qu'il faudrait réaliser et puis
les énergies renouvelables si on veut
les développer bien là aussi pour
investir
je suis désolé on ne peut pas faire les
deux donc là c'est faire croire aux gens
qu'on peut faire les deux non c'est pas
possible
merci faut aller comme l'ont montré
beaucoup d'autres pays
soit on développe l'un soit en développe
l'eau de mer et de sumo prier merci
beaucoup
roland desbordes avoir été avec nous ce
matin en direct sur rct france je le
rappelle vous êtes porte parole de la
criirad c'est la commission de recherche
et d'information indépendantes sur la
radioactivité merci à vous